several people homeless tonight after a
large fire at a mobile home park in
henderson
it started late sunday night at the alta
vista park near warm springs and lake
mead
madison kimbrough talked with those
living there about how the fire has
affected them
denise residents here at the alta vista
community describe themselves as a
family and last night's fire which you
can see behind me
spread quickly affecting the entire
mobile home park
i heard what sound like fireworks i
heard them louder and louder
i see my currents light up when it was
going on
i looked out the back window there's a
ball of fire i heard
explosions and stuff like that then i
come around the corner and i see the
fire over here
flames erupted at this mobile home park
in henderson sunday night causing the
whole park to evacuate
the cause of the fire is still unknown
but residents say
fireworks have been going off in the
area as of late
fireworks are common in this area i hear
them all the time the fire displaced
several residents and according to
henderson and clark county fire
multiple cars were damaged and eight
mobile homes are now demolished
but luckily no injuries to residents
have been reported
we couldn't come back in the park so we
all had to go
to the to the school right across the
street and we waited there until 6 a.m
power was restored to the park early
monday evening donny probert has lived
in this community for 15 years so he
wants to do something to help
i would like to get a fundraiser to go
you know for all these people that are
displaced
his commute is pretty tight and it will
happen
again the henderson fire department has
not said what caused the blaze just
yet but the red cross is assisting these
families with anything that they need a
really tight community here
at this mobile home park we really wish
them all the best reporting live in
henderson madison kimbrough 8 news now